Why should you be a facilitator or a teacher?
Why should you give your time to Startup Weekend and these entrepreneurs?
Number 1, we think you'll learn a tremendous amount yourself
just watching a variety of teams start with an idea and watch their process.
And you as a facilitator will actually watch your skills rise
as you're able to see patterns you've never seen before.
You will gain a deep understanding of the Lean LaunchPad curriculum.
That is, you'll understand business model design,
you'll understand all the components of the business model canvas
and understand the startup is not just a bunch of teams who have free food
and you bring your dogs to work and work incredibly hard.
You'll understand that there's actually a pattern here,
and the pattern is not only the strategy, the canvas,
but the process of getting out of the building,
talking to customers, and understanding iterations and pivots and know when to do that.
You will get fingertip skills that will be immensely valuable in your own career.
And then we think that being part of an organization,
bringing the democratization of entrepreneurship to a thousand cities worldwide
means you're part of something bigger.
You're becoming part of a community and a leader and a role model
for the startup community in your city and your country.
You have an incredibly important role.
And I think you understand that the Startup Weekend program
is an important part of the ecosystem in your city and, potentially, your country.
It is the catalyst in bringing entrepreneurs together
and giving them a set of skills they could never acquire elsewhere.
And you are that leader.
So I want to personally thank you for dedicating your time to something
we all believe is so incredibly important.
This entrepreneurship, this education, this Lean LaunchPad, this Startup Weekend
and Udacity is all part of a global movement that's truly impacting the world.
I'm really, really impressed that all of you have decided to participate and give all you have.
So thank you from the bottom of my heart.